President Trump has given us the
controversy for the day like a teacher
handing out the homework assignment the
controversy is should the movie parasite
have won Best Picture and is Gone with
the Wind a better movie it's a trump at
a campaign rally less and I decided to
go on an extended riff on on this
subject which is great because a lot of
people don't realize this but actually
constitutionally the president is
considered the nation's chief film
critic that's one of the enumerated
roles of president United States so it
says so right in the document so you
know it's it that's good and it happens
that he did get this one right I have to
say
he said that parasite should not have
won Best Picture now his problem is
apparently is that parasite is his South
Korean it's a foreign film that's means
not the issue the issue is that it just
is not a very good movie I watched it
myself this past weekend in fact now in
fairness I was in a delirious half-dead
State with the flu so maybe that
affected my judgment of the movie I
don't know but it really seemed to me to
be a sort of okay movie that is also a
metaphor about class struggle but the
filmmaker beats you over the head with
the metaphor that there's just no
subtlety it has all the subtlety of one
of the speeches that the dad in Full
House gives at the end of each episode
to the daughter sort of okay here's the
message of today's episode boys and
girls except that in this case in the
film there's a whole lot more stabbing
than there typically is in a full house
episode so anyway Trump is right about
parasite and I'm glad that we could have
that conversation because it is indeed
without question one of the most
pressing pressing issues that our
country faces as for the less pressing
issues I want to begin today with a case
at Shawnee State University in Ohio a
professor is being told by a judge that
he must use the preferred pronouns of a
transgender student or he can be fired
if he doesn't the professor claims that
this requirement is discriminatory
against him it violates his free speech
it violates his religious liberty but
the court said no you you can be forced
to pretend that a male student whose
feet
the court said it is reasonable for you
to be made to participate in the
delusion of a gender-confused student
there's a lot to discuss here with this
case we're gonna get into it but first
before we do a quick word from fairway
you know fairway is a family-owned
grocery chain and a top ten employer in
Iowa and they've been in business since
1938 so they've been doing this for a
long time they've over over 11,000
employees they service five stage with
brick-and-mortar locations and they did
all that before launching fairway meat
market to service the rest of the US and
December 2018 fairway announced a new
plan to help eligible full-time
employees pay off their student loan
debt what I love about this before we
even get to the product which is so
amazing is that fairway is is just a
great company they're a great American
company and they're solving problems
like student loan debt but they're doing
it in in I think the American Way which
is which is they're choosing to you know
help their employees they're doing it
independently you don't need the
government for that the fairway meat
department has always been considered
the backbone of their operation what
customers can expect from fairway meat
market calm it's still hand cut by
fairway employees to ensure the best
quality and it's the same quality they
promise at the counter now delivered
right to your home okay that's all the
great stuff about the company and
everything all that's wonderful but to
me the real point is the meat is
fantastic it's just a great product okay
now they the guys over fairway were nice
enough to ship us some of the meats
which is a great thing to come home to
at the end of the day when you've got a
big box of meat and I tried try the
sirloin the ribeye a couple the cuts of
pork and it's just it's delicious it
tastes like it tastes like restaurant
quality stuff that you can make at your
own home you don't need to be a culinary
genius like myself to do it you can do
it even if even as just a regular a
regular chef this week my listeners can
get the Heartland package valued at two
hundred and thirty dollars for just
$99.99 okay so that's over half off that
you're getting plus free shipping when
entering Walsh at checkout the Heartland
package includes eight 8-ounce all now
boneless pork chops 6-8 ounce USDA
choice ribeye steaks one mouth-watering
side dish is loaded potato baked gourmet
cheesy corn or brisket baked beans you
get all of that for more than half off
that's more than 50% off the best meats
in America plus free shipping that's
fairway meat market.com
promo code walsh and look for the
heartland package
okay so Shawnee State University
philosophy professor Nicholas dr.
Nicholas Merriweather has got himself
into trouble and his work here's the
background dr. Meriwether last year was
responding to a male students question
during class and in responding dr.
Merriweather said yes sir he apparently
refers to all of his students as sir or
ma'am and calls them mr. or miss and
then their last name when referring to
him if you can imagine it this guy
apparently believes in actually being
polite and courteous and having
etiquette okay
he's one of those one of those weirdos
anyway so he's been doing this referring
to people this way presumably his whole
life just about but this time it was a
problem turns out the sir that he was
addressing prefers to be a man even
though he is in fact a sir he was a
biological male who identifies as female
so the trans student approached the
professor after class and demanded to be
referred to by female pronouns dr.
Merriweather said he couldn't do that
now according to the Alliance defending
freedom which is the organization that's
been representing doc you marry whether
the student then quote became aggressive
circling around him getting in his face
and a threatening fashion while telling
him then I guess this means I can call
you a c-word see you next Tuesday
except he said the word before walking
away the student promised to get me to
get dr. Merriweather fired if he did not
agree to the students demands sounds
like a lovely lovely young man reading
more from a DF here's what happened next
they say quote the student filed a
complaint with the University which
launched a formal investigation as a
Christian dr. Merriweather believes that
God has created human beings in His
image as a male or female and that God
does not make mistakes to call a man a
woman or vice versa would be to say
something that is just not
to endorse an ideology that inflict
conflicts with his religious beliefs Oh
dr. Merriweather offered a compromise he
would refer to the student by his first
or last name only perfectly reasonable
compromise that respects the freedoms of
everybody involved but that was not
enough for university officials instead
they formally charged dr. Merryweather
claiming that he created a hostile
environment for the student later they
placed a written warning in his
personnel file that threatened quote
further corrective actions if he did not
refer to students using pronouns that
reflect their self asserted gender
identity the university warned dr
Merryweather that he'd be in violation
of its non-discrimination policy if he
agreed to refer to men as women while
putting a disclaimer in his syllabus
saying he was being compelled to do so
against his beliefs so apparently that
was another compromise that he did dr.
Merriweather offered he said apparently
okay I'll use the the pronoun the
incorrect pronoun but I'm going to put a
put a something in the syllabus saying
that I'm being forced to do this that
was no good either the message from the
university is loud and clear you must
endorse the university's favorite
ideology or be punished there is no room
for dissent okay so that's the lead-up
to the lawsuit and then eventually
Merryweather filed a lawsuit and all the
dr. Merriweather wants to do just to be
clear just to reiterate this all he
wants to do is do is his job he wants to
do his job as a professor and not be
forced to tell a lie that's it he wants
to do his job without being forced to
lie that's it that's his only request
he's not asking this student to do
anything he's not trying to take
anything away from this student he's not
trying to impose anything on this
student
he's even offered compromises there are
ways that the professor could refrain
from lying while also refraining from
using any pronouns that this poor
student might find traumatic but even
those compromises aren't good enough for
the student or for the university no
they need the lie the full lie so help
you God
now that brings us to the court the
latest news is that the court has
dismissed dr. merriweather's case saying
that he can you can't indeed be fired
for refusing to lie the court ruled
quote plaintiffs refusal to address a
student in class in accordance with the
students gender identity does not
implicate broader societal concerns and
the free speech Clause of the First
Amendment under the circumstances of
this case
reading out from a report in The Daily
wire says the court rejected the
professor's religious objections saying
the reasonable person standard would not
consider using preferred pronouns as
unreasonable and that the
anti-discrimination policy is quote
neutral and therefore not specifically
affecting any religious group or belief
most shockingly the court upheld the
university's position that it could not
accommodate the professor due to his
religious objection as it would then be
required to make similar accommodations
for racist or sexist views as well now
we should stipulate actually hang on
because there's another there's another
important point here that we need to
mention but first before we do a quick
word from Rock Auto rockauto.com is a
family business serving Auto Park
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers and they've
got everything that you could possibly
need engine control modules brake parts
tail lamps motor oil new carpet it
doesn't make any sense in the internet
internet age to go in physically to the
auto parts store when you could just go
online and get what you need it's it's
it's so much quicker they've got the
entire selection of everything you could
possibly need I dare you to find
something that they don't have on that
on the website because they got
everything you know and it's the
convenience you just do it at your house
you order it they send it gets there in
a couple days simple as that
rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
and choose the brand specifications
prices you prefer they got amazing
selection they've got a reliably low
prices all the parts you're ever going
to need rockauto.com go to Rock Auto
calm right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
Walsh in there how did you hear about us
box so that they know that's I sent you
okay back to this case we should
stimulate
although the professor offered the
compromise of calling the student just
by their first name or their last name
which which presumably means that you
know if this student chose a
traditionally feminine name you know I
don't know I mean let's say the student
wanted to be called Sally or Jennifer or
something presumably the professor would
call him that because the thing with the
name is you could choose any name you
want so if you say that something is
your name if that's what you want your
name to be then that's a your name okay
fine
not a problem because you own your name
in that sense you could choose any name
and it's your name
that's how names work they're very
specific to you personally pronouns
aren't like that any more than a verb is
like that or an adverb or a noun or
these these are parts of speech these
are grammatical constructs you don't own
them in that same sense you don't decide
how they are applied to you that's not
the way that language works it can't
work that way
now but there was another compromise
that was offered by the university they
said okay well if you want you could
stop referring to all of your students
according to their gender stop calling
everybody sir or ma'am and and that will
be acceptable but this compromise gives
the whole game away doesn't it because
it shows that this student it shows what
he's really up to and what the
university is really up to what he
really wants is control okay he's an
egomaniac control freak just like the
people at the University trying to
exercise power and domination over
somebody else that's it that's what this
really is that's what's really happening
every time somebody freaks out and
demands that you adopt different
pronouns
trying to control the language you use
when speaking to them and even when
they're not in the room okay that's
that's that that is an egomaniac on a
power trip if the student has some issue
with not being called ma'am how would
that issue suddenly be magically
resolved if nobody else is being called
ma'am
I mean what difference does it make to
him what the professor calls other
people how would that solve is whatever
emotional trauma he supposedly
experiences from not being called ma'am
or she or her how is that trauma
alleviated by by controlling what other
people are called
is this about the trans student trying
to stand for his alleged rights or is it
just about controlling language it would
seem to be the latter in this case which
is why he'd be fine if he could force
the professor to change the way he talks
to everyone a few additional points here
there are two ways really to threaten or
impose upon free speech one is to
prevent people from saying what they
believe the other is to force them to
say things they don't believe this case
represents the latter well it represents
both actually but primarily the ladder
and the ladder is the far more extreme
kind of free speech infringement it's
one thing to punish people for what they
say or to tell them they're not allowed
to say such and such it's another to
punish them for what they don't say and
to tell them they have to say such and
such and even worse in this case is that
the school wants to force the professor
not just to say something that violates
his beliefs but to say something that
violates reality they want to force him
to lie to speak untruth right to be
dishonest I'm not a huge fan of the ADF
in this professor making this a
religious liberty issue I'm not saying
it isn't a religious
issue it is but in a sense it is but
because it's true that the Christian
faith forbids lying and it's true the
Christian faith says that God created us
male and female but you don't need to be
a Christian to see that men are or men
and not women right the fact that
individuals with a male reproductive
organs are men that's not a Christian
fact that's not a a matter of faith or
of doctrine that's just that's reality
that's scientific reality and I'm weary
of in a sense reducing our position on
this subject to one of religious
doctrine because I think the other side
would like everyone to believe that
we're only resisting their gender
ideology because of what the Bible says
or what our churches say they want
everyone to believe that our point is a
religious one it's a religious point and
so when we refuse to do what they want
we are imposing our religion on them
that's what the other side wants people
to believe but it's not true because
it's got nothing to do with it
everything that I say on the gender
issue all of it I would say even if I
wasn't a Christian if I was Muslim
Jewish Hindu if I was atheist Buddhist
pantheist whatever it doesn't matter
I'd be saying the exact same thing
because this is about reality first and
foremost it's about truth verse fiction
so this is really not actually a
religious liberty issue it's it's even
more fundamental than that this is just
about the reality that we live in and
what's happening here is it's not that
the university is trying to get a
professor to deny his faith we that
would be bad enough the university is
trying to get the professor to deny
reality and given that this is a
university supposedly in a place of
education that's a pretty big deal
because you could all that are always
gonna be people who claim that well it's
no big deal for
universities to get professors to stifle
their religious views because there's no
place in the classroom anyway people are
always gonna be saying that but okay but
should universities be telling
professors to stifle their understanding
of biological realities too by the way
in this same vein Elizabeth Warren the
pander queen sent out a tweet yesterday
reacting to a proposed bill in Arizona
the bill in Arizona would require that
males play sports against other males
and it would ban males from playing on
female sport teams Elizabeth Warren
reacted to it saying trans athletes are
not a threat we need to protect trans
kids and all lgbtq+ kids and ensure they
feel safe and welcomed at school I urge
the Arizona Legislature to reject this
cruel bill this is is just cynical
dishonest stupid nonsense Elizabeth
Warren knows damn well this has nothing
to do with with the safety of trans kids
or already or anything all trans kids
being quote a threat that's not the
point everybody agrees that all kids
should be welcome at school all kids
should feel safe at school that's our
point our point is that when you put men
on the when you put boys on the girls
teams not to mention in the girls locker
rooms and bathrooms now the girls are
being made to feel unsafe and unwelcome
and like they don't belong in their own
areas and their own spaces that's our
point
you see here's and this is the way I
think it should be framed when you've
got them we've got a small minority of
males who are demanding access to female
sports female locker rooms female
bathrooms and they say that they will be
emotionally traumatized if they don't if
they are not granted that access
they say even that they feel unsafe if
they're not given that access okay on
the other hand you've got a much greater
number of actual biological females who
say they don't want men in these spaces
because they feel emotionally vulnerable
when that access is granted they feel
unsafe and they feel like their privacy
is being taken away here's the point
we've got two competing claims being
made in essence somebody has to win and
somebody has to lose we've got the small
minority of males and we've got the
majority of females one of these groups
we're gonna have to say to them sorry
Sol you're out of luck you got to just
deal with it we have to say that to one
of these groups now let me ask feminists
Elizabeth Warren who are you gonna say
it to you're really gonna say it to the
females you're saying in this in this
competing in this competition you're
gonna put the emotional needs of the men
over that of the of the women is that
what you're saying well that is what
you're saying but and fine go ahead and
say it and make that case but that is in
fact the case that you're making and and
then don't claim to be a feminist at the
same time because if that's feminism
then the word really just has no meaning
anymore
okay one other thing I want to talk
about today and I'm going to once again
take the minority position on something
as I as I so often do I want to talk
about a certain viral video clip that's
been making the rounds online and I
don't want to play the video itself
because given my position on this it
would be rather contradictory for me to
do so so I'll just give you the gist if
you haven't seen it there's a viral
video massively viral last I saw was
overall I think the original video on
Facebook had gotten like 300,000 plus
shares alone which is a lot and
it's a video of a young child with
dwarfism
crying devastated saying that he wants
to kill himself because of the bullying
that he suffered in school he's sitting
in the back of I guess appears to be his
mom's car and his mom is filming him and
filming it for Facebook live talking
about her son being bullied and the
child as I said is just wrecked talking
about killing himself and he's 9 years
old right now obviously for a child that
age to be having thoughts like that for
any person to be having suicidal
thoughts is terrible but for a child
that age you know 9 years old to be
thinking about that is is unimaginable
my oldest kids are not too much younger
than this kid and I simply cannot fathom
ever hearing them say they want to kill
themselves so like any person with a
soul right when I saw this video I felt
a very deep mix of sadness and anger at
the bullies and and many other emotions
because it's just it's just so it's so
terrible it really gets to you
now as often happens because this video
went viral celebrities have gotten in on
the action Hugh Jackman sent out a video
to the kids supporting him the child is
Australian and Hugh Jackman's Australian
so I guess he felt especially called to
respond which is which is great and then
of course someone started a GoFundMe
campaign as always happens with these
things and now they're gonna send the
kid to Disney World with the money the
GoFundMe account earned many thousands
of dollars in just a few hours okay so
all that is nice but I also have another
thought and it's the same thought I have
every time I see stuff like this online
and I don't understand why more people
don't have this thought or maybe they do
is just they don't feel they don't feel
secure in saying so because they're
afraid they're gonna get shouted down by
everybody and that is this what kind of
parent records their child during such
an emotionally vulnerable moment
and puts it online for public
consumption you know and I don't want to
hear about raising awareness what kind
of parent uses their child's emotional
trauma for awareness is that really your
first thought when your child is
emotionally devastated by something your
first thought is oh this would be great
for an awareness campaign what what kind
of parent thinks like that and what
right do you have as a parent to decide
for your child that their most intimate
and devastating moments are going to be
shared and consumed by millions what
right do you have to decide that this is
going to be a public spectacle ten years
from now let's think about this this
child nine years old ten years from now
he's 19 is it a grown adult you think
he's gonna be happy that the time when
he threatened to kill himself at the age
of nine is documented and online and has
been seen by millions of people do you
think he's really signing on to that you
think he understands what he's signing
on for if he even did sign on for it and
don't tell me that he agreed to be
filmed because first of all we don't
know if he did and even if he did he's
nine he has no clue what he's agreeing
to or what it means or how any of this
works that's what a parent is supposed
to be there for so I'm trying to figure
this out because as a parent I I have
I've had difficult moments with my kids
nothing nothing quite like this thank
God but I've had there have been times
when they've been very upset about
things and and I've been in a position
of consoling them and comforting them
like all parents do it has never
occurred to me to pull out my phone and
stick it in their face and then put it
on Facebook I can't imagine how that
would occur to you that thought process
needs actually your kids saying they're
crying inconsolable and so you have to
think to yourself
hold on sake let me get my phone let me
get this one let me get this on tape not
everything has to be done in public not
everything is everybody's business let
your child have privacy not to mention
there are a lot of very cruel trolls
online also so even more so than in
school people online or even worse than
they are in school and now you're
opening your bullied child up to more
bullying in fact when I saw this video
whoever shared it on twitter the on this
particular share you know I was looking
at the comments the very first comments
under the video was somebody making fun
of the child's appearance now clearly to
be an adult or anyone making fun of a
child's appearance at all especially in
this circumstance that makes you scum I
mean you are human scum you're the worst
of the worst but there are a lot of
scumbags on the internet and there are a
lot of people who say terrible terrible
things about kids even in there there
are many people on the Internet which is
to say there are many people in real
life unfortunately who have no
compunction at all about anything and
have no problem saying the worst things
about other people so your child is
already been the victim of ridicule and
now you're putting him up for more of it
who does that now the the justification
I've heard is that well this mother was
at the end of a rope and she didn't know
what else to do there was no other
solution and so this is what she did
what how is this a solution I don't
understand as a parent you know I
understand being a parent and feeling
like you're at the end of the rope and
there's a there's a certain problem
you're dealing with and you don't know
how else to solve it and you're not sure
what the solution is I understand that
but why does that translate to oh well
might as well make a viral video might
as well get the the mob involved but as
well might as well put it on Facebook
was that a solution like if you're at
the end of your rope with something like
this and I can understand maybe you pull
them out you you put you find a
different school you yeah I mean you go
into the school you kick the damn doors
down to find these punk kids that are
that are bullying your son I mean
there's there are a lot of things I
could see a desperate parent doing
but-but-but pulling out your freaking
phone and sticking in your kid's face
and then putting it online
I I don't see that as a solution and and
I don't see how a loving parent would
ever ever ever could even consider that
quote solution you know internet mobs I
have a lot of experience dealing with
internet mobs they don't solve anything
okay you don't go to Internet mobs for
solutions that that's not what they do
there are three things you can get out
of an Internet mob fame shame money
those are the three things those are the
only three things an Internet mob can do
for you
fame shame and money okay well so this
mother has gotten money out of the mob
I'm not gonna say that that was her
number one reason why she did it
or you know I'm not gonna say that it
certainly seems like that's possible I
mean there are parents who exploit their
children for internet fame so that they
can then get the GoFundMe money and all
that we that does happen it certainly
seems like that's what's happening here
I don't know and they got some Fame at
it too so yeah you got fame and money
out of it and I guess some shame for the
bullies how does that solve anything yes
the child will go to Disney World great
and he'll have a nice time that's that
is awesome okay so I and I'm sure that
would be helpful but it's not gonna stop
the bullying it's it's a momentary thing
is it'll give it's a momentary boost at
most that the kid will get out of this
he goes to Disney World he gets to he
sees the nice video messages from
celebrities you get a momentary boost
out of that it's not gonna stop the
bully in fact it only makes it worse
because now you've added more bullies
into the mix and the bullies who are
already bullying the child you think
they're gonna stop now you think you
think about a nine and 10 year old kids
are gonna stop bullying because they see
this kid on on the news now crying about
being bullied
that's not how bullies work okay the
bullies aren't going to see the the
segment on on the Today Show
and think og you know we really we
really screwed up on this one yeah yeah
we we tweet was really inappropriate we
shouldn't know they're gonna see the kid
crying and they're gonna make fun of him
more for it because that's how little
that's how kids work and bullies
especially so you get a momentary boost
you get money does absolutely nothing
whatsoever to stop the bullying does
absolutely nothing whatsoever to address
the the deeper things internally that
are happening with your child that are
making him think about hurting himself
and in exchange for that momentary boost
now you have put this online forever for
everyone to see and for the rest of your
child's life he is going to be known as
the kid in that video who said those you
know really sad and horrible things and
you have made that decision for your kid
you have decided for your kid that
that's what his life is going to be or
that at a minimum that this video and
this incident is going to be a big part
of his life from here on forward you
have decided that forum you have no
right your kid is not your your
intellectual property that you can just
use for clicks and views I get so sick
of this it's like it's not even human
you got these parents that are barely
freaking human that they would look at
their kids this way what do you need the
attention for great you got a bunch of
shares who gives a damn what does it do
for you as a parent leave your kids out
of it let your kids have a life just let
them exist let them have some privacy
let them have an emotional moment on
their own without you sticking a camera
in their face yeah you see a moment and
you know that all this would be existed
this would get a load a ton of hits so
what is that what it's about
honestly I think the same thing with I
probably should stop before I get myself
into trouble into even more trouble but
I said I think the same damn thing about
parents even when I see these viral
videos of happy moments with kids you
know of intimate personal but happy
moments many times even with that I
think why did you need to put it online
I don't understand why you needed to do
that even something like forgive me but
even even these these these very nice
videos of you know things like a child
finds out on Christmas that their
stepfather is going to adopt them and
you know and it opens the the gift and
season is very very very it's very happy
I mean I feel I feel great for the kid I
feel great for the family it's a
wonderful thing why did you need to put
it on on the internet though it's a very
personal moment why couldn't you just
have that moment with your family and
cherish it and and you have it as a
memory if you want to film it for your
own benefit so that you could look back
on it later and remember it then fine
but you don't even really need to do
that because you have the memory you
have the moment it's part of your life
now why does it do 10 million people
need to see it give me one good reason
why they need to see it all right and I
say this as someone who is on a I spend
my whole my spend my whole life on the
Internet okay so I you know I I I get it
I get I understand the the desire people
have to find content and put it on the
internet and you know but we shouldn't
be using our kids for that so that's it
we'll leave it there thanks everybody
for watching thanks for listening have a
great weekend Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle well
tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we'll
get a whole lot of that and much more
see you there